all right we're doing this hello reject
nation I'm Greg Alva this is Casey
Spivey I said your name for you I hope
that makes you happy
that's okay you should go check out
Casey's channel it's a worthwhile
channel with awesome sketches on there
right now I'm subscribed you should go
check it out as soon as you can or else
she's never coming back on this channel
you want her to come back on you gotta
go to her Channel
that's simple it's a bargain I made what
do these do it was I please do it so a
while ago John and I did a video
reaction to Bill works this video called
history of the entire world
whoa which was a mine was the best way
to put it
it is so hard to keep up with of course
this led to you gotta check out the
history of Japan so here we are history
of Japan with that in mind I wanted to
give a shout out to a man who is a male
man named John Minnie John many lives
all the way and Buffalo of the New York
of the world which is right near Japan
so this shout out totally fits last time
we talked I got to meet your wife over
Google hangout she is one hot lady
sounds like an amazing cook you're a
lucky guy
make sure you impregnate her as soon as
you can so she is always in your life no
matter what happens this is advice I
give all women let's watch history of
Japan there's a lot it's a lot good luck
you know what you're in for okay Japan
is an island by the sea filled with
volcanoes in a two
in the year negative a billion Japan
mine in the year and you can walk to it
and some people walk to it okay warmer
some icebergs melted it became an island
and now there's lots of trees so now
there's people on the iPhone they're
basically sort of hanging out in between
the mountains eating nuts up trees and
using the latest technology like stones
and bowls ding dong if the outside world
and they have technology from the future
like really good metal and crazy rice
farms yes make a lot of rice for really
really quickly that means if you own the
farm you own a lot of food which is
something everybody needs to survive
so that makes you King rice farming and
rice kingdoms spread across the land
getting lost already but this one was
the most most important ruled by a
heavenly super person or Emperor for
short dick the door it's religion once
everyone to try this hot new religion
from BX please try to miss religion he
said no said everybody try it
he said no said everybody again quieter
this time and so the religion was put
into place and all forms like meeting
the government govern more and making
the government more like China's
government which is a government that
governs more hi China
they said hi [ __ ] said China can you
call us something else other than
[ __ ] such a pain what said China and
they stole China's alphabet and wrote a
book but themselves I only made lots of
poetry and art and another book about
ourselves then they stopped moving the
capital every time the Emperor died and
kept it in one place for a while right
here and
conquered the North finally get that
squared away a rich hipster named kook
is bored with modern Buddhism visits
China and there's a better version which
is monsoon comes back reinvents the
alphabet and causes art and literature
to be ready for a long time up at the
royal palace turned into such a dream
and art that they really didn't give a
[ __ ] about running the country so if you
live outside the palace how are you
supposed to protect your [ __ ] from
criminals people poor people who could
not afford to hire samurai did not hire
samurai so they made their own military
government here
they let the Emperor still be Emperor
but the Shogun is actually in control
breaking news the Mongols have invaded
China we've invaded China said the
Mongols please respect us or else we
might invade you as well okay said Japan
so the Mongols came over ready for war
and died in a tornado but they try again
and had a nice time fighting with the
Japanese [ __ ] wasn't back and moves to
Kyoto and makes a new show and I still
dress like an emperor few monsters like
painting with less colors collaborative
poetry plays monkey fun tea parties
gardening architecture Wow it's time for
who's going to be the next Shogun
usually it's the Shogun's kid but the
Shogun doesn't advocate so he tries to
get his brother to quit being a monk and
be the next Shogun he says okay but then
the Shogun has a kid so now who's it
gonna be now on your phones and everyone
thought it's so hard that the palace
caught on fire and burned down the
Shogun actually didn't care who was off
summer didn't poetry and the whole
country broke into pieces everyone is
fighting with each other for local power
and it's anybody's game knock knock
it's Europe no they're not here to take
over they just want to sell some [ __ ]
like clocks and guns
enjoy so that's cool but everybody's now
and wouldn't it be nice to patrol the
capital which right now has lipids with
no one controlling them this clan is
ready to make a run for it the first
they have to trample this smaller clan
which is in the way surprise
smaller clan minutes and the leader of
that clan has the idea of a demon gates
the capital very well he's about halfway
through trying to bring Japan with
something that kills him and then
suddenly one sperm kills them and that
guy finishes conquering Japan and then
he confiscated everybody's swords and
made some rules and now I'm going to
invade Korea and then hopefully China he
said and failed and also died but before
he died he told these five guys to take
care of his five-year-old son until he's
old enough to be the next ruler of Japan
I thought I said yeah right it's not
gonna be this kid it's gonna be one of
us cuz we're grownups and it's probably
gonna be this guy who happens to be way
more rich and powerful than the others a
lot of people support his support not
supporting him they have a fight and he
wins and starts a new government and he
still lets the Emperor dress like an
emperor and have very nice things but
don't get confused this is the new guys
and they are very strict so strict that
close the country no one can leave and
no one can come in but they have to be
right here now that the entire country
was not a war with itself the population
increased a lot
business increase schools are built
roads were built everyone learned to
read books were published there's poetry
plays sexy times
puppet shows and Dutch Studies people
started to study European science from
books they bought from the Dutch we're
talking geography skeletons physics
chemistry astronomy maybe even
electricity over time the economic and
cultural prosperity begins to gradually
slow down
knock-knock it's the United States with
guns
Oh open good country stop having it be
closed there's really nothing they could
do so they signed a contract that lets
the United States Britain and Russia
visit Japan anytime they want
shoo-shoo and Satsuma KT best I was this
sucks
and with almost very little outside help
they overthrew the Shogunate that
somehow made the Emperor the Emperor
again and moved into Oedo which they
renamed Eastern capital they made a
dragon which was a lot more Western
they made a new constitution that was a
pretty Western and a military that was
pretty Western and do you know what else
is Western that's right
it's conference done so what can we
conquer Korea to conquer Korea taking it
from its previous owner China and then
go a little bit further and Russia
Russia's in out of nowhere and says stop
no you can't take that we're gonna build
a railroad through here to try to get
some water and Russia builds their
railroad supervised by a [ __ ] ton of
soldiers and then when the railroad was
done they downgraded to a nice a
downgrade I'm an upgrade and Japan says
can you maybe chill and Russia says how
about maybe you chill Japan is kind of
scared of Russia you'll never guess
who's also kind of scared of Russia
Great Britain so Japan and Great Britain
make an alliance together so they can be
a little less scared of Russia feeling
confident Japan goes to war against
Russia just for a moment and then they
both get tired and stop it's because
it's the nineteen hundreds and weapons
are getting crazy and all these empires
are excited to try them out on each
other meanwhile Japan has been enjoying
conquering stephan1 Civil War and the
next thing on their list is this part of
China and lots of tiny islands all that
stuff belongs to Germany which just had
were too close but because Britain was
friends with Belgium which was being
trespassed by Germany in order to get
the friends to kick Frances ass because
France is friends with Russia I decided
to kick Austria's ask because Austria
was getting ready to kick Serbia sense
because someone from Serbia shot the
leader of Austria's s her actually shot
him in the head and Britain is currently
friends with Japan so you know what that
means
I'm gonna tele to sort of let them know
and they also helped britain little here
in their disappearance instead now the
war is over and congratulations which
means you get to sit at the negotiating
table with the big dudes or they decided
who was what and yes japan gets to keep
all that [ __ ] they stole from germany
you also get to join the post-war mega
alliance of nations whose mission
statement is to try not to take over the
world the Great Depression is bad
Japan's economy is now crappy but the
military is doing just fine
[Music]
Japan invaded more and more and more and
more China and is planning to invade the
entire East you've got mail it's from
Germany the new leader of Germany yes
mustache and he's trying to take over
the world and these friends and they
invade the neighbors neighbors then the
neighbors neighbors neighbors who happen
to be Britons at home and the United
States started helping Britain because
they are Philippines and started not
helping you because the United States is
also working on a large very huge bomb
bigger than any other bomb just in case
that's my stance on the war or let's
battle but at night States is really
starting to care about their image but
then Japan spits on them in white it
challenges them to war and they say yes
and then Germany is a symbol of
friendship declares war on the United
States also so the United States goes to
war America and they help the gang chase
Germany back into Germany and they also
start chasing Japan back into Japan and
and use the banya and are curious to see
if it works so they drop it on Japan
we're a great country so happy to come
from here the United States installed a
new government inspired by the United
States government with just the right
ingredients for Japan starts making TVs
VCRs automobiles and camcorders yes they
can and also better than everybody else
they get rich and the economy goes wild
and then the miracle wears off but
everything's still pretty cool I guess
[Music]
[Laughter]
how's your brain try watching a 22
minute version of that about the world
oh I have to lay down after the last one
literally
it's too much that was not easy it was a
lot oh man this was nothing compared to
that one I got some information here
this time last time I got I got all
right amount I guess brain hurts if I
were to torture someone right I would
just lock them in a room and just have
this audio playing over over again now
some people will torch them with like
let's play the same song over and over
again I would choose this and then
before you know what they know
everything about you man like perfect
Japan is quite interesting yeah I know
it now when I watch the history the
entire world the night and there was so
much I didn't know so we like to have to
absorb a bunch of new information it
hurt my brain a lot this time around I
really picked up on how funny bill
worked he knows this is good he knows
maybe people like you and I were like
like his sarcasm in here like every
brush is over just set like that he
keeps the quippy yeah yeah the tornado
bid or like so they drop it on Japan
- shoot up - likes something that is so
fast-paced he makes in such a hilarious
format yeah so it's snappy editing he
has good timing good comedic timing so
we got from your history Japan it was
easier to digest then just like a
reading it oh yeah look Wikipedia or
something there's a lot of yeah there's
a lot of visual aid and here's so much
that would come on it I feel like it
could pass a test now would this what
did you learn let's do that let's see
what you learn would you learn well I
probably couldn't tell you any of the
names of anything or anyone but I could
tell you about how there were Emperor's
and there were samurais and in the
samurai / - right I'm right there with
you but I got from this was a reminder
that when you introduce religion
everything goes wrong oh yeah and guns I
wish they covered anime
anime is a big women it kind of did I
think yeah they got some modern-day and
they did they went okay cool by modern
days the one part I could absorb easily
[Music]
and you're like that's the hard part i
keeping up with this editing is superb
as editing is so awesome there's so many
colors in your face that you're trying
to absorb all the images as well and
then once you once you lock in on a
piece of information you got to move on
to the very next thing like in Ordos
Orbis you go to like turn off your mind
our whole commentary is about how we had
a heart this is Americans history video
there were key points where I was like I
know about that part and then a lot of
it was like I mean I would like him to
do more videos like this if he liked
history of the Philippines because all
the countries that would be awesome if
he if he keeps going maybe he has and I
just don't know but I would like more of
these I would like more of them as I
feel like watching them on repeat I
would be quite a smart cookie yeah yes
probably would have benefitted from just
taking a class instead of try no service
[Music]
oh yeah I see I that I could pick up on
the awkward what I love about this video
specifically real wise seeing how Japan
did start off so so small then it became
this blossoming thing and leading up to
like historical moment with America when
there was the invasion and all that and
then the bombings of the atom bombs
somehow that led to them becoming like
the technological masters for a long
period of time to which is such a
fascinating part of history and my dad
he loved Japan my dad live in Japan for
like a whole years oh cool teacher so I
feel like he was still alive he would
have really appreciated this video
absorbing everything
a hurricane or a volcano or something
that that covered
this is it okay so it was like it was
like the peninsula was out and then
there was like a hurricane or something
and then I covered it so immediate of
island you know I would try to find the
visual aid and put it on the video but
it's good I don't know what bargees
first thing look yeah okay land bridge
why do you like it then oh oh the
icebergs melted and then it became an
island I just think it's fascinating
because when you think of Islands it's
always like woah how do people get there
did they come by boats or they know they
were already there and then they got
rained in for that 20 seconds this is
why you come here so we can make actual
analyses happening I think we've earned
a subscription this is why some reaction
channels get crap just check out Casey's
channel it's a great sketch comedy just
just go do that instead it's much more
worth your time trust me